[Music]
this week we've got be like water pinkie
pet and and borderline living
take it away his knees they like water
my friend that personally I was like JK
mantra here good stinky dog is fine be
like water as your guys's a whole mantra
company mantra will the last month
borderline lemon is this guy right here
borderline money in the home yeah live a
life on the egg type rapper story have
you guys heard that there is this newly
released footage of Bruce we've only
ever real site report I do well I
thought you got a bit of y'all demon
yeah I didn't know it was new though
because it is so old now i new for us
because it's never before seen
oh I recently saw this one like it's a
street fight no no it's a legit sparring
ah well who the [ __ ] had been in for so
long the [ __ ] lazy editor we didn't
want to edit haha okay I get it later
not all now I know forty years later
wall at is in color so he's fighting Ted
Wong his talk to it okay Ted Wong I know
Ted Wong he looks like can Chris yeah
here yeah why should I be building dope
Bruce Lee's on the left he kicked them
before he could reach him and then after
this he fights tacky camera watch this
hiya hiya
no you can't even catch him you already
hit him under her yep he's so fast
Wow Wow
the camel guys can't even focus on
taking the picture he's like mocking
ours
the interesting thing to notice is you
don't ever really see the strike you see
when his hand comes back was late comes
back you can't even see him hit him oh
my gosh your recoil wow he's so fat
[ __ ] fat good [ __ ] that's not fair
I like the motivating music too it's
also a little bit sad cuz you know his
destiny oh he kicked them in the butt
before he could even reach and the part
that I like is that he fights the exact
same way he fights in movies yeah he
didn't change but his style holistically
it looks like he's fighting like a baby
because he's like not moving like very
minimal movement thank you are you
holding back like a mother come on Logan
[Music]
well look at that he removes twice the
speeder the other dude no yeah he just
he's just waiting he's like man this guy
is moving [ __ ] slow as [ __ ] his
slow-mo is my normal speed
let me funny it feel pretty fast takes
off his helmet and all the blood he
actually fights another guy after this
Oh in tacky camera he was like I think
he did Ikea judo and karate and then
after he trained with Bruce Lee he
became a student Oh Jeff I wonder you
know what I wonder in like those clips
is like if Bruce Lee was now here today
or if he was alive to watch how martial
arts progressed I wonder if he would
have you know within his martial arts
because his martial arts was such a
conglomeration of so many different
thing yeah if he would have added like
rapidly and ground getting to a [ __ ] he
already added a [ __ ] he couldn't arm
bars and point yeah that's amazing man
she couldn't oh is the first MMA I think
I didn't know that I didn't know that he
added like like a lot of ground game
tooshi yeah he has a lot of ground game
even put it in movies and one thing
that's really cool to notice is I don't
know if he invented jeet kune do-- here
yet but he was already executing it so
when the person was a set before he
appeared block he would use the block of
his foot and use that as a strike at the
same time so she can do is like the art
of intercepting fist it was a defense
and often yeah so as soon as the guy
steps he's already taking the the
stepping foot there will never be
another like him he's like Michael
Jackson but the Chinese one I love
Michael Jackson come but he no one can
move like boosting guys impossible after
35 all muscle man swag dude crazy swag
swag you is good-looking he also talked
about a crazy person or a philosophical
I wasn't yet philosophy yeah this
posture major he's found like a crazy
homeless person all he used to wear
sunglasses at night
Oh before the ha ha ha ha
you know why so he could stand out and
look cool all the time because when you
took a lot of the stuff that Bruce Lee
says and they say it was just like a
regular person talking to you I'm pretty
sure you told me should deposit it for
my record into the ball becomes ball but
the way he says it exactly be like water
my friend
okay my friend has that rhythm of a poet
- yeah Casey and I went to his
exhibition that they had or when we were
in Hong Kong and they had all of his
like love letters that he had written
for his wife in their store oh man I'll
be so pissed my god and then you [ __ ] it
out and out all my private [ __ ] but I
wrote to my wife is [ __ ]
sup baby give me this a week all the
homies that make me whatever knowledge
it is [ __ ] really like do you think
guys would be like haha look at this
I'll be cracking the [ __ ] up dude
there's okay so lightweight there's a
friend that I have right now in his room
in high school when I walked into it
this full forgot to take down the [ __ ]
but he wrote a poem on a napkin that he
wrote to his girl and he'll pin it on
his board
and I just started reading that [ __ ] and
that's all that he'll embarrass like
it's not laughing you're so rude it
wasn't my fault he left it up there for
me to see it What did he say I don't
know I was laughing too hard
haha Knebel wrote it on a napkin
wouldn't you hate her
ah I'm just saying that's what little
boys do though what do you girls think
of Bruce Lee let's early Bruce Lee is
like a lot of guys idols but how do you
girls feel about him I don't know enough
to feel anything outside of like dope
he's really accomplished he like you
know march to the own seat of his drum
or whatever well you know what a Bruce
Lee right now I really admire that but
in terms of like him as a pretty I don't
know do you think he's sexy I thought it
was really attractive yeah but when you
meet up with them
and knees up to your chest would you be
like you still have cuz you alpha maybe
really confidence goes a long way how is
he do you know he's probably like 5 6
and 130 I think oh my yeah yeah you want
that
probably not till that Bruce Lee has a
way of working his work he'll know
somehow magic confidence gets any girl I
know why is it going big [ __ ] might
even like Tom Cruise he dated all really
tall and shoes he's about the same son
and he I heard that they make doorways
his height who you looks normal as you
guys here know what yeah I heard that's
pretty common like I did that for
Stallone too because the loans like five
five five six or something really yeah
he would wear like elevated shoes yes
yes confidence is everything is Kitty
home just call yes I think so
she saw him or there's like maybe an
inch Nicole Kidman's really tall yeah I
wonder if they carry him like this one
look it maybe he's extra tiny alright
for our next story there is a family in
New York that owned a skunk as a pet do
they removed of the the the poop grand
think yeah yeah so this pets name is
seven and seven they got from an exotic
pet store and yes it was surgically
removed
oh that's up no that's good
I don't like that I love skunks how are
you loves gone they look so cool they
look furry and they look like they want
you to hug them huh I know they look so
fluffy so i'ma show you guys a video of
seven and his family okay
why do guys take him away I like you woo
seven all five pounds of him is a skunk
opossum are white who lives in this
house with Gloria and her kids and has
become part of the family it's like I'm
a parent because I had to like take care
of him why do you have a pet skunk
because this unique Gloria says she just
had to have one after seeing an albino
skunk at a pet store Oh beautiful here
is temperament very beautiful there's
he's so cute he's like a little baby so
she put it in order for one at this
exotic pet store and yes in case you
were wondering the manager here says it
is legal to have a skunk as a pet in
New Jersey where now I know what you're
all thinking what about the smell factor
but Gloria says her skunk scent glands
have been surgically removed so there's
no need to make a big stink they don't
shed they use a litter box or we've had
her head they use a litter box
no that's pretty cool you didn't have to
walk in on the street no yeah they did
say like every day they got side walk to
something oh good you guys know like I
really wanted to have a small dog like
back right after college that we didn't
have any money to buy a dog so I decided
that we should try to get a hamster to
basically the same things we went to
Petco and my friend worked there so I
was like can I try walking a hamster to
see bit worse hold on so she when it got
like a gecko like body strap put it on
and I tried buddy strategy do you can
watch the echo and then I put it on and
I tried to walk in and it have kind of
slightly dragging it for five seconds
okay can you stop happen I don't know
have a small dog oh you gotta get your
hamster if you walk a hamster you could
just like make it to the door and it has
is tired like if you think about it
aren't hamsters like the same size like
a teacup Pomeranian which is like
thousands of dollars like maybe a guinea
pig maybe again you know you can
probably walk a guinea pig yeah I mean
you have to motivate the hamster and put
like a torch behind it Oh forward and
then you can walk for maybe like a mile
any positive reinforcement in the front
put a carrot in the front and fire in
the back oh I think like any pigs are
interesting because there's a place in
this world would they eat them regularly
yep
screw or something getting their food my
nephew has a guinea pig that kind of
lived forever I feel like he's had it
for like seven years or something and
I'll go on that part yeah beeper the his
guinea pig only purrs for him so when he
comes up yeah and Q testing
yeah yeah I kind of want to
[Music]
you know right by my house there was
this one really late night and it was
really dark but I saw this mama skunk
path right in front of my my place and
then I feel like three little big no
away right behind her it was a cutest
thing ever I ran like towards them but
obviously we got scared and what if a
quadruple spray do yeah well I wasn't at
all
I made sure there was a distance but I
try getting a video of it and I got a
video done did you see white stripes a
little bit you can see a little bit but
the babies were supposed to be me that's
a little I think if I had to choose
between like um I would choose a record
Oh
alright it's okay squirrel raccoon or a
skunk I will go with the squirrel just
because when they be like run they look
so cute I like well Coons because
they're troublemakers like climate
raccoons will [ __ ] up your dogs yeah
that's not what not unless you cross I
follow pumping the ranked raccoon on
Instagram and follow those friends with
his dogs and how many followers is
honking has like a few million I think
oh my man or 2 million well and your
pictures of him like hugging the dog
away like she's like about to dive into
the pool she's so cool I'm curious what
kind of brand deals is punkish cuz I
know right okay oh my god that's right
right because raccoon products they must
be really good because I've never seen
an ad please nobody give me brand deals
we have the hardest brand to freaking
wanna sponsor all these like some milk
companies want to [ __ ] anybody yeah
that's why you don't get it because the
ones that are about to give it to you
column [ __ ] cleaner oh well I
at the same time I'm thinking about my
fan base because I don't want to show
you guys [ __ ] garbage no matter how
much money they throw at me and you
complain about another sponsor I know
but you guys have great sponsors don't
you not I mean like people such as like
Toyota hits you up you know let me a
[ __ ] Geo Metro they shouldn't even
exist anymore haha Oh God
right a kid that's that's the key
he felt family-friendly ha me use my
child up so much I'm waiting for it man
child labor so awesome alright for our
last story there is this home that first
sale
that is literally straddling the US and
Canada border whoa so is it considered a
u.s. home or a Canada home I was trying
to find that out too because I was
trying to figure out like what are the
legalities here within house yeah so who
collects the property tax yes any
questions yeah maybe I couldn't find
answers to these questions but I do know
other thing I think the fact that this
home was built in 1782 whoa yeah it's a
7,000 square foot home just [ __ ] fish
it's kind of 2 5 currently vacant
apartment Oh
the home was inherited to this couple of
that selling it 40 years ago so they're
there now saying that it's really
difficult to sell a home that's in cue
country but it's being sold for a
hundred and nine thousand dollars to
have that do that's so cheap I have a
thousand square foot house up huge it
must be like in the middle of nowhere
that it's in Vermont and yep remember
that was a state I didn't even know the
mode touch cañedo for a hundred and nine
thousand dollars in LA you will you
could buy a garage yeah maybe a working
bathroom maybe maybe yeah you can't buy
[ __ ] in LA wait can you even get a
trailer
hmm 400,000 you know one those
stationary one the one that are in the
trailer place one really really good
okay so you can barely get one because
I'm gonna have some shirts it adds up
everything so expensive here this is a
couple are selling the home why don't
they just stay there
but it's haunted I'm telling you this is
the home Oh
line you can see the actual border that
is actually kind of amazing that is
really make it like an Instagram hotspot
oh yeah the I when I demand this I
didn't see a lot of people standing in
the middle going the funny thing is the
border between USA and Canada has no
police and no one checking anything yeah
I'm not sure they do so they do mention
that they have a really close
relationship with the Border Patrol on
both sides it looks way different than
the entrance and do you want to know
yeah yeah but there's flowerpots
covering this border
there's no barbed wire no come over
eight maybe and it's written they also
have like a line across their home oh
dude I do that all day like I'd be like
let's go to Canada I don't enter and you
go on the other side you eat dinner and
you can call your kids illegal
immigrants on the other side so cool
yeah but this home is a fixer-upper
they're estimating that the cost $500
600 600 thousand dollars to fix a
hundred thousand on whole bus - burn it
ha ha ha damn yeah don't feel how's it
big the places though oh you that place
is [ __ ] huge look at a university it
idea that here's a place even have
running water 7,000 square feet right
and it's an apartment go to the
compartment complex - so yeah the
property income they're just buying the
land and the broken-down 1700s would
know wow they're talking about how back
in the day it was like nice and friendly
cuz everyone got along again after the
9/11 attacks and everything just got
really Hospital on the border and that
now like apparently there was this one
Border Patrol agent that was new and he
didn't really know the family and then
they had like this whole ordeal with
that guy cuz he didn't know that they
lived there it was just because he was
standing in front of his home he was
like giving him issues so it's like a
big headache till seven times my [ __ ]
house bro was weird
yeah he was a Canadian or American
American of course of course maybe the
sign dirty Americans a so there are
Canadian couples and they actually have
dual citizenship Oh what school yeah you
got I do and they have family in Canada
and the US to time the son of a [ __ ]
I thought you couldn't have dual
citizenship imagine maybe you can with
countries that US is friends with Jax I
I heard it was illegal US citizen
no I mom have tools and just loaded my
cousin didn't you you're not really able
to say that no people have it but it's
rationally really is it I think it
depends on the nation because like if
it's a friendly nation to the US it's
different from like you know us and like
oh no cuz I know the US doesn't allow it
but if you go to like other countries
like Mexico they would they're like yeah
you can have it here doesn't matter what
others oh they don't want you baiting
taxes they want to keep your money or
they want to keep your money so they
want you to report your taxes here so
you can pay this country nobody take my
money people that do a dual citizenship
they are not paying double taxes if
they're being a proper dual citizen
they're paying double taxes you pay so
much in Texas hey you guys want to stock
any of us we'll go ahead down to the
description box below and you can follow
us on Instagram and all kinds of stuff
for more videos
[Music]
you